Wir wollen jetzt blicken auf den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Wir blicken heute nach Italien, nach Spanien, nach England und wir tun das mit Christian Bernhard, mit Nies Kan und mit einem neuen Ensemble-Mitglied, möchte ich fast sagen. Chris McCarthy ist mal hier. Wir werden ihn gleich vorstellen nach dem hier.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Linien. Immer mal wieder denke ich mir bei diesem Intro, es ist einfach zehn Sekunden zu lang, aber das liegt ja an dem schreienden Kommentator, weil es so lustig ist, dass man ihn von Anfang bis Ende im Hintergrund schreien hört. Und er hat einfach nicht aufgehört. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr im Rasenfunk mit dabei seid. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, die gewohnte Runde hier zu haben und aber auch ein neues Mitglied. Chris McCaffey ist hier mit dabei. Er ist freier Journalist. Er war früher Gründer von 90 plus und er wird uns über die Premier League aufklären in der Zukunft. Chris, schön, dass du da bist. Sag doch mal ein paar Worte zu dir. Hi.
Das hat Titelmaterial. Ultimo ballo.
Ja, das checkt dann wieder keiner. Der ultimative Ball. Muss sich ja um den letzten Ball handeln, oder? Genau, der letzte Ball ist immer der schwerste. Das sagen ganz, ganz viele Teams, wenn sie im Angriffstrittel angekommen sind. Aber ein Grund dafür, warum sie es manchmal sagen, ist, bisschen weirde Überleitung, ist Maxence Lacroix. Ja, wir sind jetzt bei Chris Tepeles gelandet, denn gegen ihn ist der letzte Ball wirklich auf der letzte Wahl, denn Lacroix hatte ihn wieder. Chris, du möchtest ihn mal kurz hier aufs Podest heben, weil er sehr stark spielt gerade.
Ja, ich muss erst sagen Respekt. Ich hab nicht gedacht, dass die Überleitung, also ich wusste nicht, wie du die Überleitung machen willst, aber gut. Ist dir gelungen.
Herzlich willkommen in der Liga Tour. Da wissen alle eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig, wo ich gerade hin will.
Ja, Maxence Lacroix ist wirklich einer der besten Spieler der letzten Wochen in der Premier League. Ich würde jetzt das Chris machen, aber macht keinen Sinn, weil ihr schon wisst, dass es um Crystal Palace geht, aber Crystal Palace hat nach Liverpool in den letzten sieben Spielen die meisten Punkte geholt. Also sehr formstark, fünf der letzten sieben gewonnen, vier davon zu Null. Und das hat natürlich auch mit Lacroix zu tun, der in der Dreierkette von Oliver Glasner im Zentrum spielt. Im Sommer, als er verpflichtet wurde, war man noch so ein bisschen kritisch. Das lag vor allem daran, dass er auch im Anderson verkauft wurde, der eigentlich so der Abwehrchef war der letzten Jahre bei Fulham, wurde aber für 30 Millionen verkauft. Bei Crystal Palace wurde 30 Millionen an Fulham verkauft und Lacroix wurde für knapp 20 geholt. Und jetzt weiß man auch wieso, hat ein paar Anfangsprobleme gehabt. Aber ich meine, wir alle kennen auch seine Qualitäten aus der Bundesliga, unglaublich schnell, physisch stark, kopfballstark, wirkt jetzt auch immer souveräner und selbst wenn er einen Fehler macht oder einen Stellungsfehler macht, dann ist seine Schnelligkeit einfach wieder da, der Schlüssel gegen vollem jetzt zuletzt absolut herausragend, eine tolle Rettungstat gegen Krimines, wer sich sowas anschauen möchte und auf Abwehrszenen steht, ich finde es immer ganz spannend. Dazu auch sehr anticipationsstark, der ist bei Taclins im 94. Perzentilen der Premier League Unterverteidigern, bei Interceptions, also abgefangenen Bällen, 92. Also super Werte. Hat jetzt auch einen Sonderlob von Oliver Glasner bekommen, hat gesagt, dass er auch ein fantastischer Führungsspieler geworden ist und er hat gesagt, dass manche Spieler führen mit ihren Worten, manche mit ihren Aktionen und die Besten machen beides. Und das war das Lob für Lacroix. Und ja, man muss halt echt sagen, für knapp 20 Millionen Euro, da darf man sich jetzt mittlerweile fragen, warum hatten denn nicht andere Kaliber auf dem Zettel? Weil das ist für Premier League Verhältnisse, für so ein Profil schon relativ günstig. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es dann Sommer vielleicht die eine oder andere Anfrage geben wird.
Weißt du, wie ich mitbekommen habe, dass Lacroix offenbar ganz gut spielt gerade bei Crystal, weil ich seinen Namen im Zusammenhang mit Virgil van Dijk gehört habe und eben dem auslaufenden Vertrag, was da dran ist und so weiter, keine Ahnung. Das war in irgendeiner, weiß gar gar nicht, könnte auch auf Blue Sky gewesen sein. Aber da dachte ich mir so, okay, wäre nicht mein erster Gedanke gewesen, ich glaube bei dem läuft es gerade. Dann kam dein Themenvorschlag jetzt ein paar Tage später, da dachte ich mir, okay, gut, hiermit ist es bestätigt. Maxence Lacroix, bei dem läuft es ganz gut. Aber noch ganz kurz die Situation insgesamt bei Crystal Palace. Also es hat sich jetzt wieder ein bisschen stabilisiert. Es war so Tabellen, man ist ins untere Drittel abgerutscht. Jetzt ist man wieder im grauen Mausbereich. Ist das letztlich auch dann okay, gemessen an dem, was der Verein haben möchte? Ich meine, wir haben ja über Crystal auch schon mal gesprochen in dieser Saison. Da lief es noch ein bisschen schlechter. Also wie würdest du so allgemein die Lage des Vereins einschätzen?
Also gerade wenn man sich den Saisonstart anschaut, dürfte man jetzt wirklich absolut zufrieden sein. Vor allem, wenn man bedenkt 36 Punkte nach 27 Spielen, das ist tatsächlich der beste Punktestand in der Premier League Geschichte des Klubs nach 27 Spielen.
Krass. Okay.
Von daher dürfte man relativ zufrieden sein. Letzten Wochen hat auch wirklich die Offensive auch gut nachgelegt. Man hat so das Gefühl, dass Oliver Glasner so ein bisschen die Offensivspieler etwas von den taktischen Zwenken befreit hat. Ist alles ein bisschen frei fließender, ein bisschen kreativer. Aziz ist natürlich auch vorzuweben im offensiven Mittelfeld. Saar hat jetzt zweimal getroffen. In Ketja von Arsenal kommen im Sommer hat jetzt ein erstes Premier League Tor gemacht. Als Stürmer ist das natürlich nicht ein berauschender Wert, aber es scheint ja jetzt in die richtige Richtung zu gehen. Also man dürfte bei Crystal Palace relativ zufrieden mit deinem Entwicklung sein.
Kein Wunder, dass man einen 100 Millionen Euro Preistil auf Oli Glasner draufgepackt hat, als der FC Bayern seine Fessin lösen lassen wollte. Ja ja, interessant, wie das doch so alles verläuft und wie irgendwie alle Geschichten, die wir hier so im Laufe der Jahre besprechen, immer wieder sich miteinander verstricken. Nies, jetzt wollen wir nochmal in La Liga blicken und wir haben vorhin schon mal das Thema Salary Cap gestreift. Jetzt wird es richtig aktuell. Ja ja, wir haben darüber gesprochen bei der finanziellen Situation von Liverpool. Und jetzt wird es aber richtig heftig, denn Sevilla hat es erwischt.
Sevilla hat es auch vorher schon erwischt. Also erst mal noch generell, La Liga versucht jetzt seit fünf Jahren Gehaltsobergrenzen nicht nur zu zeigen, sondern auch durchzusetzen. Das ist jetzt nicht immer gelungen. Auch Basel wurde ja mal auf 200 Millionen runtergestufen. Das ist halt immer so nach den Transferphasen im Spätsommer. Jetzt im Spätwinter, Februar letztens wieder, wurden da diese Gehaltsobergrenzen angepasst. Das sind die Gehälter im gesamten Club, also auch für Trainer und Jugendmannschaften und normale Mitarbeiter. Also Manchester United wär da direkt raus oder würde da noch mehr streichen wahrscheinlich. Es geht auch darum, nicht nur fixe Gehälter, sondern auch variable Gehälter und Kosten mit reinzunehmen. Und da gibt es halt jetzt an sich nicht so viele große Veränderungen. Reamatritis weiter mit 754 Millionen kann am meisten ausgeben. Basel wird hochgeschuft von 426 auf 463 Millionen Euro. Ja und dann gab es schon in der letzten Anpassung im Herbst einfach einen Verein, der nur 2,5 Millionen Euro ausgeben durfte an Gehältern im gesamten Verein. Wie soll das schon mal möglich sein? Hat man sich gedacht, okay vielleicht gibt es da Konsequenzen, weil dieser Verein wird bestimmt drüber sein. Das war da schon der FC Sevilla und jetzt nach dem Winter Transfermarkt, wo der Sevilla auch Jesus Navas Karriereende montiert nach Argentinen verkauft, davor kam auch Vargas aus Augsburg. Jetzt wurde dieser Club noch mal runtergestuft auf 684.000 Euro, was ein kompletter Verein an Gehältern ausgeben darf. Wie soll das möglich sein? Also jetzt redet man nicht darüber, dass es natürlich unmöglich ist, da irgendwie diese Zahlen einzuhalten. Jetzt redet man darüber, dass dieses Salary Cap so gut ich den Ansatz, das Konzept auch finde, finanzielle Fairplay, ein bisschen transparente Zahlen, Clubs sollen nicht mehr ausgeben als sie einnehmen. Finde ich an sich gut den Ansatz, aber jetzt gibt es da jetzt mal Konsequenzen, weil der FC Sevilla, wage ich mal die Vermutung, dass er schon bei den zweieinhalb Millionen Euro der Grenze drüber lag und jetzt bei 684.000 Euro auch da vielleicht mehr Ausgaben hat an Gehältern. Also da macht sich La Liga vielleicht ein bisschen lächerlich mittlerweile, wenn es jetzt keine Konsequenzen gibt.
Moment mal. Also wir hatten das ja schon thematisiert, als es die zweieinhalb Millionen waren. Weil da gab es ja schon die Geschichten, rein theoretisch müssten die jetzt selbst wenn die immer zum Bus anreisen und nur noch die Spieler mitnehmen, selbst dann würden sie schon irgendwie über zweieinhalb Millionen landen. Da gab es so Modellrechnungen mit Hotelkosten und so weiter und so fort. Und wir wissen ja, dass bisher die Sanktionsmöglichkeit war, du darfst dann Spieler nicht registrieren, bis du nicht eben nachweisen kannst, dass du das gegenfinanzieren kannst. Wie ist denn das jetzt bei Sevilla? Also warum werden die nicht sanktioniert oder wie werden sie sanktioniert?
Ja, ist ein gutes Rätsel, was ich auch noch nicht rausfinden konnte. Wie gesagt, war ja auch schon mit den 200 Millionen, gab es da jetzt auch noch keine Konsequenzen. Oder als Baas ja mal auf 200 Millionen runtergesetzt wurde. Auch die konnten dann hier und da noch mal Jorah Felix registrieren oder auch ein Gabi. Darum soll es jetzt hier nicht gehen. Wirklich, es geht auch darum, zum Beispiel, Espanol ist auch eine Mannschaft mit nur einem Budget von 7,8 Millionen Euro. Auch das, ich meine, das nehmen ja, nehmen dir zehn Spiele aus dem Kader und da ist das Budget dann schon voll und 684.000 Euro. Das zahlst du ja schon an Gagen für deine Liga-Tour-Experten quasi. Das ist ja, also wie, das fehlt ja völlig die Praxis, der realistische Bezug in der Umsetzung, weil ja, Sevilla hat finanzielle Probleme und musste auch deswegen in den letzten Phasen immer mal ein paar Spiele so in Fernando noch abgeben. Rakitic musste schnell wieder weg als Kapitän. Navas jetzt Karriereende, auch wenn er eh schon leicht verletzt war, von dem das war geplant. Aber es sieht halt nicht danach aus, als würde es da jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise Konsequenzen geben, weil natürlich konnte Sevilla auch einen Vargas registrieren. Und also das ist jetzt das, was ich meine, La Liga macht sich da mehr und mehr lächerlich. So gut der Ansatz auch ist mit Celery Cap einzuführen, aber wenn da Vereine dann trotzdem irgendwie ständig drüber liegen, und wir reden ja nicht nur, dass Sevilla so knapp jetzt noch zwei Millionen Geld hat, sondern normale Vereine hat ja trotzdem irgendwie an seine 100 Millionen Geld oder was auch immer im gesamten Club. Das wird ja scheinbar dann trotzdem jetzt keine Konsequenzen haben wie Punktabzug, Zwangsabstieg, was auch immer, ohne dass ich mir das wünsche für den FC Sevilla. Aber wenn La Liga schon so transparent und in Zahlen veröffentlicht.
Aber das heißt quasi, im Celery Cap ist auch gar nicht festgehalten, was eben passiert, im Falle, dass jemand das wiederholt, sich nicht dran hält.
Nicht wirklich. La Liga versucht zumindest hier und da in seinen Pressemitteilungen immer zu nennen, was alles dazugehört, hatte ich ja genannt, auch die Mitarbeiterkosten und auch die variable Gehälter, aber ohne genaue Konsequenzen. Also sie sagen, guck mal, du darfst nicht mehr ausgeben, du, du, du. Aber Sevilla lag schon über den zweieinhalb Millionen und Sevilla wird auch über den 684.000 liegen. So wie Barca auch über den 200 Millionen lag vor zwei Jahren. Von dem her ist das ja ein bisschen eine Fass geworden, dieses Celery Cap, aber immer wieder, jedes halbe Jahr vielleicht nett ist, hier mal in der Liga-Tour zu erwähnen, hören, Hörerinnen hören, was da teilweise krumme Sachen laufen in der Liga.
Absolut. Und generell muss man sagen, eigentlich ist ja dieser Schritt der Transparenz gut. Also ich fände es gut, wenn wir ähnlich wie im US-Sport manche Zahl wüssten, die jetzt immer nur so gerüchtet wird. Ist ein bisschen schwieriger mit EU-Arbeitsrecht, Datenschutz und so weiter und auch Privatsphäre. Also man kann das auch kritisieren, wie es im US-Sport ist, dass man da quasi bis auf den Dollar Cent runterrechnen kann, wer was wann bekommt und so weiter und so fort. Aber ein bisschen einfacher wird es für uns dann machen, manche Dinge zu verstehen, glaube ich. Weil so wird immer geraunt im Hintergrund. Und das wäre eigentlich zu begrüßen, damit Transparenz zu haben. Ein Stück weit ist das ja in der Liga so. Also gut geht es im FC Sewea nicht. Das wusste man aber schon vorher. Die haben durch die Europa League Gewinne relativ oft ihr wirtschaftliches Ergebnis verbessert und hatten vor allem auf der Transfereinnahmenseite viel zu wenig Ertrag über die letzten fünf Jahre hinweg. Das war eben früher das, was sie so ein bisschen durchfinanziert hat, war eine wichtige Säule beim FC Sewea und das hat dann immer mal wieder gefehlt. Und dann kamen sie schon nach Corona, hätten sie schon eigentlich auch nach UEFA-Richtlinien sanktioniert werden können. Aber sie kamen noch mit der Corona-Ausnahmeregelung durch und haben es dann in der darauffolgenden Saison geschafft. Ich glaube, da haben sie dann wieder Europa League gewonnen oder irgendwie so. Müsste ich jetzt noch mal nachgucken, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist relativ hoch, dass es so war. Und dann sind sie damit dann wieder quasi da rausgekommen. Aber da hatte sie quasi die UEFA auf ihrer Beobachtungsliste, aber eben noch nicht auf der Sanktionsliste. Naja, tja.
Mehr Antworten kann ich euch da auch nicht so geben. Aber vielleicht gibt es in zwei Monaten dann so, jetzt ist doch Punktabzug für Sevier, irgendeine Konsequenz einfach mal, um zu sagen, ja, ihr habt doch mehr ausgegeben als 86.000 Euro.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich habe in meiner Verzweiflung per Plexity gerade noch gefragt, also die künstliche Intelligenz, warum werden die nicht sanktioniert? Und hier wird viel einfach nur aufgelistet und am Schluss steht, es ist wichtig zu beachten, dass Sanktionen nicht immer in Form von Punktabzügen oder Geldstrafen erfolgen müssen. Die auferlegten finanziellen Beschränkungen sind bereits eine Form der Sanktionierung, die darauf abzieht, den Verein zu einer verantwortungsvolleren Finanzführung zu zwingen. Und wenn das die künstliche Intelligenz so formuliert, dann müsste ich jetzt noch irgendwie zweimal prompten, um die Quelle zu finden, wo er das rauskopiert hat. Wahrscheinlich steht das irgendwo im Kleingedruckten beim Financial Fair Play von Laliga mit drin. Oder es ist komplett ausgedacht. Darf man auch, kann natürlich auch sein. Aber deswegen habe ich ja meine natürlichen Intelligenzen hier. Heute waren es drei. Ich danke sehr Christian Bernhard. Sorry, Max, darf ich? Bitte, ganz kurz. Ich hatte einen ganz, ganz kurzen Rausschmeißer, nur für Fußballromantiker. Na komm. Ganz kurz, den muss ich noch unterbringen. Pippo Insagi, sagt wahrscheinlich hoffentlich noch ein paar Menschen was. Der mittlerweile nicht mehr so erfolgreiche Insagi-Brüder, wenn es um die Trainerkarriere geht, ist Trainer in Pisa, ist Zweiter in der Serie B, also ist auf dem besten Weg in die Serie A aufzusteigen. Und die, wie ich finde, schöne Geschichte, die wollte ich jetzt einfach noch kurz reinbringen, hat vor kurzem auf die Bank zum ersten Mal einen jungen Herrn, 17 Jahre Jung namens Luis Buffon mitgenommen. Jetzt könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich denken, was die Vorgeschichte zu Herrn Buffon ist. Ja, Gigi Buffon ist sein Papa. Das wollte ich einfach unterbringen, wenn der Trainer Pipo Insagi, den 17jährigen Sohn von Gigi Buffon, ist übrigens ein Offensivspieler, durfte zum ersten Mal mit bei den Profis. Und ist auch schön, Buffon, der ja mittlerweile eine offizielle Rolle im italienischen Verband in der Nationalmannschaft hat, hat an der Tage auch gesagt, der Junge, er will nicht das Gefühl haben, dass er da irgendwelche Abkürzungen hat wegen seines Namens, deswegen spielt er für die U18 von Tschechien. Dann seine Mutter ist Tschechien und ja, wie gesagt, fand ich sehr nett, Pippo und Sage mit Louis Buffon. Ja, doch noch was für Fußballromantik. Ja, wir werden wirklich alt, ja. Das hört sich an wie ein Doppelsex-Freude. Ja, ist richtig. Ja, aber wirklich. Und gleichzeitig natürlich lustig mit welcher abgeklärt hat dann Buffon, die Familie Buffon dieses mögliche Thema, das ja noch gar keins ist, angeht. Wenn wir drüber nachdenken, könnt ihr euch noch erinnern, wie groß die Aufregung englischer Boulevard-Medien war, ob der Sohn von Harry Kane in Deutschland auf deutschen Boden zur Welt kommt. Großes Thema, ja. Man nimmt einen leichten Unterschied wahr. Also sehr schöner Rausmeister, vielen Dank. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich Christian Bernhard Nieskern und Chris McCarff. Wie schön, dass du mit dabei bist, Chris. Hat große Freude gemacht mit euch dreien. Danke euch. Danke auch. Danke schön. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, die 100.000 an Euro, die wir an Gästehornoraren zahlen, die kommen von euch, denn alles, was wir hier machen, ist paywall, Werbe und Sponsoren frei. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Andi, bei Herrn Mosbach, liebe Grüße bei Tobi aus Freiburg, bei Taktik-Tafel F172, der jede Form von Halbfeld-Flanken liebt. Okay, also er ist ein pervers Link. Nein, vielen Dank, schön, dass du da bist. Es gibt sehr, sehr schöne Halbfeld-Flanken. Und Kovie Bryant hat uns auch unterstützt in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Herzlichen Dank dafür auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht mit einem Betrag eurer Wahl und in der Höhe eurer Wahl. Und im Grunde habt ihr eigentlich auch die freie Zahlungsmittel-Methodenwahl. rasenfunk.de einfach auf den Unterstützen-Button klicken. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die es getan haben. Und abonniert doch auch sehr gerne unsere anderen Feats. Wir machen Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer, zur Bundesliga der Frauen. Gerade ist eine Folge zu den letzten beiden Länderspielen der Frauen erschienen im Nationalteams-Feed. Und es gibt noch den Trembüngen-Gespräch-Feed. Da haben wir über das Polizeikosten-Urteil des BGH kürzlich gesprochen. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund. Bis bald.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.